welcome to this video playing Andrew
Martin one known in a British chess
coach and author also player of course
but is well known for his DVDs and books
okay let's see we have a very soft
opening she's going form a sort of
reversed stone wall but with a knight on
c3 yes this is quite quite honey looking
but not bad I have seen something like
that in a book some an interesting way
to play for white okay how to develop
now yeah well be six Bishop e7 is some
it's looking like a solid option but
it's not really very active okay I need
to I need to get going though okay this
is interesting he obviously wants to get
in Queen to h4 so maybe I need to
preempt that interesting
hmm yeah this looks dangerous it looks
dangerous I probably need to go is 6m to
prevent that chair even a sacrifice is
dangerous at least in a blitz game it's
dangerous and maybe it's objectively
strong okay he didn't sacrifice but it's
also not necessary really didn't need to
to do any fancy stuff yeah but how bad
is this position I mean I have some
ideas to get his bishop this would be
nice maybe that's not the mayor that's
not so bad huh okay yeah I need to keep
again keep this closed of course mmm now
and now take here and very dangerous and
age five maybe maybe
yeah that's a very very dangerous
position for me but okay I have some
ideas I mean I have a substantial threat
year queen bee aid if he does not react
to that I'm almost winning the game
because I get you five and his position
falls apart hmm I have the two bishops i
mean if if it's not killing me right
away of completely ignoring my thread or
isn't it the thread yeah i thought this
would be very good to be honest i just i
just take five next and and then then
it's really gone if he loses his five
night the position is completely useless
and f6 i just take with the porn and win
win the peace even
and this was probably at one point
really critical look very dangerous yeah
I can take I can take with the the pawn
and okay I'm so is trying to make a
piece sacrifice out of it but I can also
just take take here with the night maybe
that's even easier I can also take here
I may be Queen at five ok I'll keep it
simple just keep it simple this is how
many points two pawns and undo good
position quite resigned yeah it's only
bit early but white is indeed my white
is lost yeah thatthat's kids clear but
can could have still try to to make make
some problems yeah and is this it looked
very dangerous effort I really didn't
look at f5 yeah computer just says /
luck is better yeah immediate is not
completely impossible if I get the
bishop parents and have to nicely
positioned bishops to control the center
but still I'm surprised this looks this
looks shaky this
yeah and here of course he knew he
absolutely must react to queen bee eight
I mean this is some surprising that he
didn't do anything against it it was
them I thought relatively clear threat
the comp wants to take and then play
something like that yeah that's so
that's a good good way to play covering
deform and just keeping the game going
as may be Queen g5 h5 ideas this is a
movement to have the Queen to swing over
yeah that's completely unclear I mean
complicated everything can happen
anything can happen yeah this just just
lose this probably when here like this
is probably objectively better but I
wasn't I wasn't completely sure and I
can go we for young or here and here I
always have before to stop all kinds of
attacks something like that so here
there's even Queen 86 yeah then taking
the pieces even even better this is the
the play it safe way until we reside
early really but it's two pawns it's two
bishops and white really has no no big
player okay thanks for watching